the folks at this quarry in clafton near
lancaster dig up about 60
000 tons of shale rock from the ground
every year that shale needs to get to
the brickworks about a mile and a half
that way
nowadays you'd have some fancy
underground conveyor belt or
you just have trucks loading up and
driving back and forth
but this quarry opened in the 1920s so
the solution was a bit different
an aerial ropeway this is the last
aerial ropeway in britain it's nearly
100 years old
it needs no fuel and no electricity to
run and in 15 years time
it'll be gone this roadway was
commissioned in the 1920s
but we've been quarrying from this
valley now for well over 150 years
an empty bucket arrives it goes on to
what we call the bull rail
so that automatically comes off the rope
and it allows the rope to go around
their wheel
the bucket then is dusted if the weather
is bad the rain
adheres to the bucket and the muck
sticks to it so that would reduce
what is taken down to the factory and
also would it would affect the balance
of the rope
and then it puts under a feeder where a
given amount of material is pruned to
that bucket
about a quarter of a ton at that point
another operative
takes the full bucket from under the
feeder and waits till the
correct positioning of the incoming
bucket is in place
allows him then to feed it onto the rope
that spacing is critical
because of the way the rope works it's
gravity fed
the brickworks is downhill from here so
all the power for this ropeway comes
from gravity
put the full buckets of shale on one
side going down the hill and the empty
buckets on the other side going up
and you don't need an engine house or a
motor you just need brakes to regulate
the speed
it takes about half an hour for a round
trip there are about 40 buckets this
ropeway will move about 300 tons of
shale
every day with no need for petrol or
electricity
so let's go to the brickworks at the
other end and see how it works down
there
as the bucket comes in the other end an
operator is stood waiting for it
it comes off the rope at a given speed
onto a bull rail
from that bull rail the operator walks
round there's a pivot system on the
bucket
that tips into a hopper at that point it
then feeds
into a dump truck the operator then puts
the bucket back
when the correct space is positioned he
pushes the bucket onto the rope
it's an hour to swing that bucket and
tip it at the right time they do walk
quite a few miles in a day
this factory was designed to produce
round about 42 million
bricks annually there was a 4.4 million
investments
four years ago that increased the
productivity up to 50 million
crafton produces frost resistant product
it's down to the shale from the quarry
that's a vital key to it the temperature
we fire at and also the durability of
the ceramic
bond that means we can sell this product
into all extreme
weathers there's nowhere in the uk we
can't sell to
with our durability of the product at
clafton unfortunately has to cross the
road it's never been known
certainly in the last 50 60 years to
come off at that point
but it is a possibility so we have a
steel bridge with big
bucket catchers on the side that would
prevent that happening the rope
construction
is a 25 millimeter steel rope very
difficult to get contractors these days
who are skilled in splicing ropes of
that size
we replace the rope every six years it's
a very very difficult process
very old the technology is the 1920s of
course
we did a computer design of a new
roadway many years ago
and unbelievably the computer matched
this design in terms of trestle heights
and weights
to somebody with a slide rule and a
pencil there used to be hundreds of
these ropeways around britain in
industrial sites mines and quarries
this is the last one still operating
anywhere in the country
it nearly wasn't the financial crisis in
the late 2000s meant that the quarian
brickworks
shut down for a few years but it was
kept in working order and as of right
now
it's still transporting rock but it has
an expiry date
31st of december 2036. permission for
quarrying was going to end in 2018 but
the local council planning department
granted an extension because
the quarry and brickworks are still
operating there's a lot of shale
still in the hill up there and literally
no one objected i checked the planning
report
environmental agencies local residents
everyone was like
yeah fine keep it running that works now
in theory that deadline could be
extended again but the reason they pick
2036 is that by then
the company will more or less have
quarried everything they can out of that
hill
and one of the conditions of that time
extension is that once quarrying is
finished
the ropeway has to come down the
planning report does acknowledge that
it's unique in the country it's the only
one left in britain there is
some heritage value in it but they say
not enough to justify saving it for
posterity
this isn't like an old railway line
where if it's left unmaintained it'll
just slowly steadily decay
it could be actively dangerous if the
ropes and towers start to fall apart
particularly when they run over a road
just there unless money is constantly
spent to keep it in working order
it'll decay into an unsafe blot on the
landscape
which is fair but i suspect when that
final day comes in about 15 years time
when the last bucket goes down the
ropeway
there'll be a few people here to say
goodbye to it and until then
it'll keep moving shale without needing
any fuel at all
thank you so much to all the team at
forterra for showing me around they did
ask me to make clear that the ropeway is
not a tourist attraction so
if you're in the area and you want to
take a couple pictures from the road
sure but then for their sake
please keep driving
you